allora
mamma mia
tutti
per
è davvero finita qui
caridi suoi newton fuori e calmo ok a
morena rest now inizia dai dai dai dai
dai
no dai
senti contanti folla
si no
la porta
all
la notte tra il 18 19 aprile del 2015
circa 900 persone sono colati a picco a
85 miglia a nord della libia
quel giorno quella notte eravamo a pochi
chilometri da roma
nella nostra assemblea generale di ogni
anno e da quel momento ci siamo detti
che era la misura era colma che era il
momento di fare qualcosa al di là delle
classiche proteste al di là delle nostre
testimonianze su un comunicato stampa
qualsiasi e e fu così che decidemmo in
qualche modo di cambiare rotta anzi di
prendere la rotta di iniziare un
attività in mare di ricerca e soccorso
cambiando per sempre in maniera
definitiva la nostra identità
fino a quel momento non abbiamo mai
fatto cose di questo tipo la competenza
mancava era necessario formare c era
necessario trovare il modo di noleggiare
un mezzo per per poterci muovere perché
lo lo facciamo perché fondamentalmente
nell'ottobre del 2014 il governo
italiano decise di sospendere l'attività
di mare nostrum
lo fece poi definitivamente il 31
dicembre di quell'anno a fronte di molte
promesse fatte dal governo per mantenere
una sorta di funzione di ricerca e
soccorso internazionale per lo meno
europea o italiana in realtà questo non
si concretizzò e quello che è successo e
fu uno stillicidio di morti che
raggiunsero le 1.500 al all'inizio del
maggio del 2015 non potendone più
decidemmo quindi di di noleggiare un
mezzo quindi troviamo questa questa
imbarcazione 77 metri poderosa che abbia
un nome
suggestivo bourbon argos appena vedemmo
questo nome pensammo tantissimi in alla
mitologia greca gli argonauti e quindi
per noi quando iniziamo il nostro
cammino sulla burbon argos partimmo con
questo buon auspicio
andiamo a recuperare di fatto il vello
d'oro andiamo a tentare di curare le
persone
quello che successe immediatamente dopo
fu molto diverso ed è quello che voglio
raccontarvi oggi improvvisamente dopo
alcuni giorni di navigazione trovammo
un'imbarcazione più o meno come questa
non è non è esattamente questa ma è
molto simile
un'imbarcazione in pessime condizioni un
peschereccio probabilmente libico o
egiziano che si staccava pezzi e lo
trovammo fermo con 50 centimetri d'acqua
nella stiva in condizioni veramente
molto difficili quando lo vedemmo
arrivando ci chiediamo quante persone
potevano esserci dentro qualcuno di
sulla 100 150 200 persone
iniziamo a le manovre di ammaraggio e
piano piano le persone una volta
arrivate da noi le contano centro 17
bambini 147 donne e tantissimi uomini
alla fine della conta 497 persone
salirono a bordo
queste persone quando sono salite a
bordo ci hanno raccontato la loro storia
è una storia mi ha colpito moltissimo
una persona che ha visto una telecamera
una telecamera di un nostro collega si è
messo davanti alla telecamera eto'o per
favore film e ha registrato 15 secondi
di clip molto rapida e in questa clip
dice due cose io all'europa non chiedo
soldi non chiedo che voi siate contenti
e felici per avermi io chiedo solo che
voi abbiate l'opportunità a mio figlio
di poter crescere e di non vedere quello
che ho visto io a questo chiedo
all'europa
questa è stata la cosa è immediatamente
il punto di vista nostro su queste
persone è cambiato in maniera
incredibile eppure da 20 anni ci
occupiamo anche di immigrazione in
italia da più di dieci anni ci occupiamo
di immigrazione a lampedusa in alto
prima non avevamo mai fatto questa
constatazione non sono disperati sono
gli eroi sono gli argonauti sono persone
che si mettono in cammino si mettono su
una nave e largo se in questo caso e
vanno dritti verso il loro destino per
dare futuro ai propri figli per cercare
il vello d'oro e da cosa scappano da da
questo
questa è la clinica di sel ma è un
ospedale in siria vicino ai d league
dove noi riferivamo alcuni pazienti
ortopedici sono arrivate due bare bones
due barili colmi di oggetti in ferro e
tnt che arrivando dall'alto sganciate
dagli elicotteri e fanno quello di quel
danno all'interno di quella clinica
ovviamente non si poteva più operare
alcuni pazienti sono rimasti gravemente
feriti
ed è una delle tante situazioni da cui
da cinque anni ormai i siriani tentano
di scappare e ovviamente non ci sono
solo siriane ci sono persone che
scappano da crisi importantissime come
la crisi del mali
una guerra assolutamente sottaciuta come
le situazioni di oppressione e
gravissime dell'eritrea come le
situazioni altrettanto gravi dei diritti
dell'uomo in gambia e situazioni che
ogni giorno noi vediamo e constatiamo
non solo accogliendo le persone ma
soprattutto lavorando nei paesi da dove
loro scappano e e quindi che cosa
facciamo li accogliamo e questa è una
parte dell'accoglienza una fotografia di
lampedusa un ragazzo che scende
disidratato una nostra infermiera che
l'utente di idratarlo in condizioni come
vedete abbastanza misere sulla banchina
del porto e spesso queste persone
arrivano entrano in una situazione come
questa questo e cassibile ci sono due
campi coltivati di patate 1 da un lato
uno dall'altro in questa striscia che
loro in maniera ironica e sardoni che
hanno chiamato la striscia di gaza
vivono vivevano per lo meno 400 persone
qualche anno fa
che raccoglievano le parole durante il
giorno e dormivano in quelle misere
condizioni con l'acqua raccolta in
quelle in cui in quei contenitori a
circa quattro chilometri di distanza
feci e urine ovviamente disperse nei
campi vicino una condizione
assolutamente intollerabile di queste
situazioni in italia si stanno
moltiplicando
l'anno scorso ne descrivevamo circa
15mila persone in queste condizioni in
condizioni analoghe in situazioni in cui
non venivano gestiti nei
dall'accoglienza ordinaria che a 30mila
posti solo 30mila posti in italia e
nemmeno dall accoglienza straordinaria
che ne ha tra i 70 agli 80 mila
l'europa ha fatto recentemente degli
accordi non solo il più famoso quello
con con la turchia che prevede il fatto
che tutte le persone transitanti nel
corridoio balcanico in particolare in
grecia rientrino il più velocemente
possibile verso la turchia e e poi dalla
turchia ci sia un processo che dovrebbe
ricollocare delle persone in un tempo
ancora non chiaro ma questo processo
questo processo ignobile dal nostro
punto di vista che ha fatto sì che che
meglio senza frontiere non riceverà non
accoglierà più fondi dall'unione europea
perché negli ultimi due anni 2014 2015
raccoglievamo circa 122 milioni per
alcuni progetti di mezzi senza frontiere
nel mondo perché non li raccoglieremo
più non solo perché un accordo a nostro
modo di vedere assolutamente non etico e
assolutamente illegale ma anche perché
sta diventando la moda con cui l'europa
farà degli accordi in maniera crescente
con i paesi africani con i paesi del
medio oriente
eppure continuiamo ad accoglierli così
li continuiamo ad accogliere tentando di
portare a loro di dare a loro umanità
accogliendoli sul sulla barca dicendo
welcome e non respingendoli e tentiamo
di farlo in modo in modo nuovo noi
vorremmo che le persone cambiassero
narrativo sui migranti c'è stato la rete
visto qualche giorno fa un vademecum di
emma bonino molto molto interessante su
8 cose da assolutamente sapere sui
migranti e 8 balle da ribaltare 8 bugie
che sarebbero da smontare pezzo per
pezzo e convincere le persone che
veramente le persone non guadagnano 35
euro al giorno che i migranti non
prendono il posto di lavoro a noi che i
migranti sono un orda barbarica
ricordiamoci 130 140mila persone che
arrivano a fronte di milioni di persone
cioè sono 65 milioni di persone al mondo
in questo momento in fuga ci sono dei
paesi che pur essendo miseri poveri
riescano ad accogliere in maniera
dignitosa alle persone ed è quello che
secondo noi dovremo fare dovremo
considerarli del degli eroi le cose da
fare ed è la mia call to action
il mio appello a fare qualcosa è
molteplice da un lato ci sono delle
delle campagne quella che sta sulla mia
maglietta milioni di passi è un esempio
la possibilità di andare nelle scuole di
portare un kit didattico e di spiegare
in poche in poche lezioni in pochi
momenti la situazione che moltissime
persone che milioni di persone vivono in
questo momento la loro difficoltà le
loro storie ricordiamoci una cosa molti
di voi qui hanno avuto il privilegio di
avere dei nonni o dei genitori che hanno
vissuto la seconda guerra mondiale o
delle situazioni veramente molto
complicati del dopoguerra e sono dei
racconti che in qualche maniera hanno
scaldato nel nostro cuore sono una parte
importantissima della nostra identità
ora purtroppo per ragioni anagrafiche ci
sono sempre meno persone che raccontano
queste cose noi abbiamo la possibilità
oggi di incontrare delle persone che
vengono da altre situazioni e sentire le
loro ordalie la proposta che vi faccio è
per chi può per esempio dare
l'opportunità a queste persone di
imparare l'italiano con un'ora o due
alla settimana e avere in cambio
barattare la loro storia la storia del
loro paese la storia delle loro
avventure tragiche delle loro ordalie
per arrivare fino a qui io credo che sia
una cosa molto molto importante altre
cose da fare molto concrete sono per le
10 15mila persone che in questo momento
stanno un po sparse per l'italia in
condizioni pietose e molti di voi lo sa
non lo quello conoscono facciamo delle
cose molto concrete
fosse solo prepariamo un thermos da
portare in stazione la sera mi rendo
conto con un atto caritatevole non
normalmente non una cosa che
un'organizzazione non governativa
internazionale fa ma io credo che sia un
atto concreto bellissimo e
importantissimo perché tutti un po tutti
i progressisti tutti noi che siamo qui
oggi ho molti di noi sono delle delle
tigri sono degli attivisti fintanto che
rimangono sulla tastiera io credo che
invece oggi dobbiamo veramente fare uno
sforzo in più
credendo che servire dare supportare non
un film un gesto assolutamente difficile
assolutamente triste o politicamente
corretto sia veramente un grandissimo
vantaggio per noi perché sentire le
storie che questi eroi raccontano
secondo me è una cosa importantissima e
chiudo con con un saluto e vado e in
moltissimi paesi questa è la repubblica
centrafricana fine del 2013 conflitto
tra antibes alla ca cristiani e ex eleca
musulmani conflitto sanguinoso durissimo
combattuto a machete combattuto ad archi
e frecce